Francia en llamas.
Todos hemos visto estas imágenes.
Durante varias jornadas, a finales de junio
y principios del mes de julio, el país galo vivió
una vez más una situación de absoluto descontrol.
Las protestas, los saqueos, el fuego y
los tumultos desatados en las principales
ciudades de Francia recorrieron el mundo entero.
Claro que estas imágenes han dejado de ser algo
extraordinario en este país. Sucesos e imágenes,
más o menos similares, se repiten cada
poco tiempo y cada vez con más intensidad.
No importa si hablamos de reivindicaciones
y protestas raciales o religiosas,
de la final de la “Champions”, de los chalecos
amarillos o de las reformas de las pensiones. La
violencia empieza a ser un signo distintivo
cualquier movimiento social en este país.
La última ola de disturbios provocada por el
disparo mortal de un policía contra Nahel Merzouk,
un joven de 17 años, se saldó con más de 5.000
vehículos calcinados, más de 1.000 propiedades
dañadas o saqueadas, 269 comisarias atacadas
y más de 4.000 personas detenidas. Una locura.
Sin embargo, no nos engañemos, estas
protestas no pasarán a la historia.
En la Francia de hoy la última ola
de violencia, será tan solo eso,
la última ola antes de que dentro de no
mucho tiempo se produzca la siguiente.
Eso es algo que va a ocurrir… E, incluso,
seguramente lo haga antes de lo que podamos
imaginar. Porque queridos amigos, amigas de
VisualPolitik, Francia empieza a estar rota,
el país corre un serio peligro de implosión
y cada dos por tres surgen las llamas.
C1 (“Es como si Francia fuera una olla a
presión, [cada crisis] revela tensiones,
un conflicto en la sociedad… Nuestro país está
constantemente invocando valores republicanos,
pero parece que segmentos enteros de
la población no sienten que eso les
importe” Bruno Cautrès, investigador
político en declaraciones a Politico).
La situación ha llegado a tal punto que
durante las protestas el presidente francés,
Emmanuel Macron, llegó a
defender ideas como estas:
N1 (“Macron sugiere bloquear las redes
sociales durante los disturbios. Le Monde)
Pero, ¿qué demonios está pasando en
Francia? ¿Por qué la sociedad parece
rota? ¿Qué está detrás de estas enormes olas
de violencia? ¿Qué consecuencias pueden tener?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os vamos
a contar cuáles son los 3 grandes protagonistas
en todo este caos que cada dos por tres se desata
en Francia. Los 3 grandes protagonistas que nos
permitirán entender mejor lo que está ocurriendo
en el país galo y por qué París y las otras
grandes ciudades del país se están convirtiendo
en las Ghotams de Europa. Solo que en este caso
sin que podamos encontrar ningún Batman a la
vista… Aunque como veremos algunos lo pretendan.
Vamos con ello.
T1 (LOS BANLIEUES: LA MECHA)
Queridos amigos para entender
esta historia tenemos que
empezar remontándonos hasta mediados del siglo XX.
Como en otras muchas grandes
ciudades de Europa y de América,
París y otras grandes ciudades francesas
se estaban expandiendo a toda velocidad.
La industrialización y el éxodo del campo a
la ciudad estaban multiplicando su población.
Un fenómeno que en el caso de Francia se
vio multiplicado por los procesos de
descolonización de su viejo imperio.
(Pues bien, para dar una respuesta al
hacinamiento de las ciudades y a la
aparición de auténticos barrios
de chabolas e infraviviendas,
a partir de los años 60 comenzaron a crecer
los suburbios de las ciudades: los famosos
“banlieues”. Lo hicieron en París, en Lyon,
en Marsella y en el resto de grandes ciudades.
Se desarrollaron bajo la dirección del
propio estado francés que empezó a promover
miles y miles, decenas de miles de vividas
sociales en estos nuevos barrios en los que,
por supuesto, también se abrieron
escuelas, centros médicos y líneas
de transporte público. Sobre el
papel la idea era fantástica.)
Con estos nuevos barrios y con las miles
de viviendas públicas construidas por el
gobierno, los franceses más pobres
no solo podrían acceder a una casa,
sino también a un estilo de
vida mucho más acomodado.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, los problemas
no tardaron en surgir. Ya sabéis que de la
teoría a la práctica hay un techo y que
las intenciones no garantizan resultados.
Inicialmente, la mayoría de las viviendas
se destinaron a los propios franceses que
emigraban del campo, pero estos
en cuanto podían se mudaban a
barrios considerados mejores. ¿Y qué
ocurría con las viviendas libres? Pues
que fueron adquiridas o pasaron a manos
fundamentalmente de población inmigrante.
Al mismo tiempo, la desindustrialización que París
ha experimentado en las últimas 4 décadas cerro
las puertas a buenos trabajos y buenos salarios
para muchos de los vecinos de estos barrios.
Y así, de esta forma, estas zonas se
terminaron convirtiendo en algo así
como un sinónimo de pobreza, inmigración
y todo tipo de problemas: fracaso escolar,
discriminación, desempleo, edificios mal
mantenidos, delincuencia… Digamos que poco
a poco estos suburbios empezaron a
convertirse en auténticos guetos.
(Este fue un fenómeno especialmente intenso para
muchos grupos de inmigrantes procedentes del
caribe, de Senegal, de Costa de Marfil,
de Marruecos y sobre todo de Argelia,
que han terminado viviendo en barrios
separados, donde se mantiene la presión
cultural de sus países de origen y
donde los niveles de integración con
la sociedad francesa son relativamente
bajos. En los últimos años, por ejemplo,
está llegando mucha población de países como
Pakistán. Y claro, como os podéis imaginar,
la combinación de una cultura tan rígida con un
entorno de ghetto es una bomba de relojería.)
Ahora bien, no os penséis que esto ha pillado a
nadie de nuevas. En 1977 el gobierno de Francia ya
mostró su preocupación de que
se estuvieran formando guetos.
Y aún más, tan solo en los últimos 20 años
el estado francés se ha gastado la friolera
más de 60 mil millones de euros en una campaña
colosal para renovar bloques de viviendas, mejorar
las infraestructuras y acondicionar todo tipo de
instalaciones en estos barrios, particularmente en
los más pobres donde viven más de cinco millones
de personas, la mitad procedente de Argelia.
De hecho, durante las últimas protestas seguro
que todos habéis podido ver cómo se quemaban
bibliotecas, escuelas y centros de salud. Y
lógicamente si las han quemado es que las hay.
C2 (La salud es gratuita, la escuela es gratuita,
y a veces tenemos la sensación de que
nunca es suficiente". Emmanuel Macron.)
Además, durante años también
se han creado montones de
organizaciones pagadas por el gobierno
para intentar que las cosas mejorarán.
Sin embargo, pese a todo los esfuerzos, lo cierto
es que los resultados han sido bastante pobres
Los banlieues son ampliamente conocidos
por sus altas tasas de desempleo,
de fracaso escolar, drogadicción, pobreza
y delincuencia. Es un auténtico desastre.
Porque además muchas de las personas que
viven en ellos, especialmente los niños,
no lo tienen nada fácil para escapar de ellos.
Y es que, queridos amigos, amigas,
cambiar las cosas materiales resulta
relativamente sencillo. Basta con
tirar de chequera. Sin embargo,
no ocurre lo mismo ni con la
cultura ni con las personas.
Por ejemplo, las escuelas de estos barrios tienen
unas altísimas tasas de fracaso escolar y su nivel
académico tiende a ser mucho más bajo. Esto hace
que muchos estudiantes se queden por el camino.
Pues bien, esta política de vivienda pública que
terminó promoviendo auténticos guetos es una de
las claves que explican por qué Francia tienen
tantos problemas para integrar a los inmigrantes.
Por así decirlo, los inmigrantes llegan a Francia,
viven en Francia, sus hijos nacen en Francia,
pero nunca terminan de ser franceses. Al
menos no del todo. Los datos son muy claros.
Por ejemplo, se calcula que cerca del
50% de los niños de esta especie de
guetos son pobres. El desempleo es casi el
doble que la media nacional y por supuesto
los ingresos de las familias son mucho
más bajos. Para que os hagáis una idea,
uno de cada cinco extranjeros que viven en
Francia piensa que es discriminado por su origen,
por su raza o por su religación. Es una
las tasas más altas del mundo desarrollado.
Amigos, Francia es uno de los
países qué más problemas tienen
para integrar a los inmigrantes. Y estos
barrios tienen buena parte de la culpa.
¿No me creéis? Pues… Fijaos en este gráfico.
("Todavía hay una sensación en estos vecindarios,
y probablemente una realidad, de que no tienes
tantas oportunidades como en otros lugares,
cuando ves a tus padres y hermanos mayores
luchando por encontrar trabajo. [...] Estamos
pagando por la concentración de la pobreza, la
falta de diversidad en las escuelas y la negativa
a construir viviendas sociales fuera de estos
barrios" Olivier Klein, Ministro de Vivienda y
asuntos urbanos y exalcalde de Clichy-sous-Bois,
un municipio de los suburbios orientales de París)
Lógicamente, todo esto genera frustración. Y,
amigos, no lo dudéis, la frustración es
el mejor ingrediente para la violencia.
Para colmo en los últimos años han surgido
dos nuevos problemas en estos barrios:
Primero, el narcotráfico.
N2 (El suministro de cocaína alcanza un
máximo histórico en Francia. LeMonde)
El consumo de drogas en Francia ha crecido
un montón en los últimos años. Se estima que
tan solo la cocaína tiene más de 600 mil
consumidores habituales en el país galo.
Eso ha hecho que surjan muchos grupos mafiosos
que operan, precisamente, desde estos barrios.
Y, por otro lado, está el problema
del integrismo religioso. Son en
estos suburbios dónde vive la mayor parte
de la población musulmana de Francia. Y,
amigos, la falta de oportunidades,
el sentimiento de no pertenencia y la
frustración han formado un gran caldo de
cultivo a la hora de reclutar fanáticos.
No sé si os acordáis, pero antes de
la pandemia, los atentados yihadistas
en Francia estaban a la orden del día.
Pues bien, la mayoría fueron perpetrados
por personas de origen argelino que vivían,
¿Sabéis dónde? Exactamente, en los banlieues.
Lo que lógicamente ha contribuido a
crear una enorme espiral de desconfianza,
violencia y recelos que no ha hecho más
que agravar el problema. Por ejemplo,
las personas de origen extranjero
que viven en estos barrios tienen
20 veces más posibilidades de
ser parados por la policía.
Una policía que no siempre es
particularmente amigable. Lo
que nos lleva directamente al segundo
protagonista de toda esta historia.
Atentos.
T2(LA POLICÍA: ¿LA GASOLINA?)
La policía es con diferencia una de
las instituciones más poderosas de
Francia. Entre otras cosas porque
está fuertemente sindicalizada.
La policía tiene muchísimo peso político.
Y en los últimos años el incremento del
integrismo yihadista, las cada vez más
habituales protestas contra el gobierno
y el aumento del narcotráfico
les ha dado todavía más peso.
Desde comienzos de siglo, Francia ha
aprobado una nueva ley de seguridad
que refuerza a la policía prácticamente
cada año. Por ejemplo, pueden emplear
armas intermedias en sus patrullas en los
suburbios, algo particularmente infrecuente
en el resto de Europa. ¿Otro ejemplo?
Se les ha dado facultad para parar e
identificar a quien les dé absolutamente
la gana sin que exista motivo alguno.
E incluso, desde el año 2017 se permite a la
policía de tráfico emplear la fuerza letal
contra cualquier conductor que huya de un control.
De hecho, aunque os pueda sorprender, el caso de
Nahel Merzouk no fue algo inédito. El 7 de junio,
apenas tres semanas antes de la muerte de Nahel,
la policía de París mató a una chica joven,
de 21 años, que supuestamente se había
negado a detenerse en un control.
El 14 de junio, dos semanas antes de la muerte
de Nahel, la policía también acabó con la vida
de un trabajador de reparto de tal solo 19
años, guineano, en otro puesto de control.
En total, tal solo en los 18 meses anteriores
a la muerte que desencadenó las protestas,
la policía francesa acabó con la vida
de 17 personas en controles de tráfico.
Y eso no es todo. En general, hablamos de una
policía que acumula un montón de denuncias
por excesos de todo tipo y que como os podéis
imaginar es muy poco popular en los suburbios.
Y viceversa. Según las encuestas, los agentes de
policía se identifican desproporcionadamente
con partidos como el de Marine Le Pen,
que piden mucha más mano dura. De hecho,
tras desatarse las últimas revueltas,
los dos grandes sindicatos de policía utilizaron
un tono tremendamente incendiario. Llegaron a
decir que estaban en guerra contra hordas de
salvajes y que tenían que acabar con las ratas.
Lo que, bueno, ¿Qué queréis qué os diga?
Podréis tener la opinión que tengáis,
pero no sé, declaraciones así no parecen
invitar a calmar las cosas, ¿no os parece?
Poca broma con la policía francesa.
De hecho, esto es lo que el propio
Macron decía en 2017, fijaos:
C4("Quiero cambiar la cultura, el
estilo de gestión y el reclutamiento
de la fuerza policial". Emmanuel Macron en 2017)
Sin embargo, luego llegaron
los chalecos amarillos,
las protestas por la reforma de las pensiones
y demás… Y claro, Macron ya no quiso nada
de pegarse con la policía… Y sobre todo
con sus sindicatos. ¡Lo que le faltaba!
Por supuesto que la policía sea incapaz de
controlar los suburbios y que la población
de estos barrios confié tan poco de ella no hace,
sino echar gasolina al problema
de los guetos que ya hemos visto.
Claro que con toda esta historia
no todo el mundo sale perdiendo.
El tercer gran protagonista de todo
este desastre… No es sino el gran
beneficiario de toda esta historia.
¿Alguna idea? Pues… Atentos.
T3(LA EXTREMA DERECHA: LA CONSECUENCIA)
La última ola de violencia se ha saldado
con un claro ganador: Marine Le Pen.
Los franceses empiezan a estar hartos y
Le Pen ha sabido capitalizar como nadie el
momento. Le Pen y su partido aprovecharon los
disturbios para atacar al gobierno de Macron,
pero también para presentar un
paquete de medidas de mano dura.
La Agrupación Nacional, la formación de Le Pen
quiere que a partir de 16 años los jóvenes pueden
ser juzgados en procesos penales como adultos,
quiere que los condenados por delitos pierdan el
derecho a vivir en viviendas públicas o a recibir
cualquier tipo de pago o contraprestación del
estado. También quiere que se encarcele
a mucha más gente y reducir los pagos
sociales a las personas que viven en estos
suburbios de los que os estamos hablando.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Este es algo que empieza
a gustarles a los franceses… Y ojo,
no lo decimos nosotros. El 30 de junio
se hizo una encuesta que mostró que la
respuesta de Le Pen ha sido la mejor valorada
de todos los líderes políticos de Francia.
C5("La escoria que vemos pillando tiendas,
incendiando bibliotecas y ayuntamientos,
todo mientras se ríen, no están haciendo esto
por Nahel. Es una excusa para atacar a la
policía y todo lo que representa a la república".
Edwige Díaz, diputado de la Agrupación Nacional)
Y es qué… Pese a todo, el apoyo a la policía ha
seguido siendo bastante alto entre los franceses.
Según una encuesta publicada por Le Figaro,
el 7 % se puso del lado de la policía,
mientras que el 69 % respaldó declarar el
estado de emergencia, que era, por cierto,
otra de las peticiones de Le
Pen. Menudo tanto político.
Amigos, el caldo de cultivo que se está
gestando en Francia es… Delicado. Por un
lado, está la frustración de los
suburbios, por otro el yihadismo,
luego tenemos a los partidos más radicales
creciendo a toda velocidad. Esta es la gran
amenaza de implosión de Francia. Un país en el
que ya nos podemos encontrar noticias como estas:
N3(Recaudación de fondos para un oficial francés
que mató a un adolescente recauda más de
1,5 millones de dólares. WashingtonPost)
Claro que, un momento, porque esto
no solo está ocurriendo en Francia.
Lo cierto es que el tema de
la inmigración y, sobre todo,
los problemas de integración que han generado
muchas de las políticas que se han puesto en
marcha en las últimas décadas se está
convirtiendo en un material explosivo.
Francia recibe mucha atención, pero no es un
caso singular. Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os
hemos contado cómo Suecia está también teniendo
serios problemas de violencia. En este país,
la policía ha identificado a 31.000 personas
que o bien forman parte o tienen estrechas
conexiones con las más de 50 pandillas
que han disparado la violencia en el país.
C6("Nunca nos hemos enfrentado a una
criminalidad tan despiadada [...] El
modelo de organización de todo el sistema de
justicia sueco no está preparado para hacer
frente a una criminalidad tan extensa" Anders
Thornberg, Jefe de la Policía Nacional de Suecia.)
Y ojo con Bélgica o, incluso, Alemania.
En la gran potencia europea el número
de delitos se ha disparado… Lo que
ha hecho que la intención de voto
del partido de extrema derecha Alternativa
por Alemania este subiendo como un cohete.
En total de los 27 gobiernos de la
Unión Europea, solo seis se inclinan
a la izquierda. Y dentro poco puede que
aún sean menos. En los últimos 18 meses
se ha producido un tremendo giro político
en toda Europa. Y aquí la inmigración y
sobre todo los problemas de integración están
jugando un papel absolutamente fundamental.
Por eso llegados hasta aquí el turno
y la pregunta clave es para ti:
¿Cómo atajarías los problemas de Francia?
La inmigración es imprescindible y, además,
tiene efectos económicos muy positivos, pero,
¿Cómo se puede mejorar la integración de las
primeras y, sobre todo, las segundas y
terceras generaciones de inmigrantes?
Dejadme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
y abramos debate. Y ahora si este vídeo
os ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.